Robert Spencer here for Jihadwatch, a
program of the David Harowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy with some new information about
Barack Obama's fantasy Islam. Ibid
Mubarak. Mr. President, Obama's
fantasies about Islam made a new
appearance recently when he issued a
statement congratulating and praising
Muslims on the occasion of the Muslim
feast of Eid alaha. Obama said this,
"Michelle and I extend our warmest
wishes to Muslims across our country and
around the world who are celebrating
Eidala. The special holiday is a time to
honor the sacrifice, resolve, and
commitment to God demonstrated by
Abraham." Now, in speaking of Abraham,
it is important to remember that there
is no parallel in the Quran to Genesis
22 15 to18 in which Abraham is rewarded
for his faith and told that he will
become a blessing to the nations.
Genesis says, "By your descendants shall
all the nations of the earth bless
themselves because you have obeyed my
voice." Now the Muslim audiences Obama
was addressing, they don't read the book
of Genesis. They read the Quran. In the
Quran, Allah says that Abraham is an
excellent example Hassana, a term
applied also to Muhammad himself in
chapter 33:21 of the Quran. Abraham is
uswah Hassana an excellent example for
the believers says the Quran when he
tells his pagan family and people that
quote there has arisen between us and
you enmity and hatred forever unless you
believe in Allah and him alone that's
chapter 60:4 the same verse goes on to
say that Abraham is not an excellent
example when he tells his father I will
pray for forgiveness for you so you see
hatred is held up as exemplary
forgiveness is explicitly declared to
not exemplary. Obama was thus
reinforcing a worldview that takes for
granted the legitimacy of everlasting
enmity and hatred between Muslims and
non-Muslims. And he was doing so
precisely in the context of trying to
build bridges between Muslims and
non-Muslims. Obama also said that Eid
was a celebration of the ways faith can
transcend any differences or boundaries
and unite us under the banners of
fellowship and love. Yes, indeed. Just
look at how the bombs in New York and
the stabbings in St. Cloud, Minnesota,
and the jihad attacks in Fort Hood and
Boston and Chattanooga and Garland and
San Bernardino and Orlando, as well as
Paris, Brussels, Nice, and all the rest.
Think about how those united us under
the banners of fellowship and love. Of
course, Obama would insist that none of
those attacks had anything to do with
Islam. All the evidence that refutes his
politically correct fantasies is simply
waved away. The national conversation
that needs to be had about how jihadis
use the texts and teachings of Islam to
justify violence and supremacism is once
again as ever kicked down the road.
Obama added, "As we mark Eid alata this
year, we are reminded of the millions of
refugees around the globe who are
spending this sacred holiday separated
from their families, unsure of their
future, but hoping for a brighter
tomorrow. And as a nation, we remain
committed to welcoming the stranger with
empathy and an open heart. From the
refugee who flees war torn lands to the
immigrant who leaves home in search of a
better life. Now about those refugees.
Akmed al- Muhammad and one other of the
jihadis who murdered 130 people in Paris
in November 2015 had just entered Europe
as refugees. In February 2015, the
Islamic State boasted it would soon
flood Europe with as many as 500,000
refugees. And the Lebanese education
minister said in September 2015 that
there were 20,000 jihadis among the
refugees in camps in his country.
Meanwhile, 80% of migrants who have come
to Europe claiming to be fleeing the war
in Syria are not really Syrian. An
Islamic State operative boasted in
September 2015, shortly after the
migrant influx first began, that among
the flood of refugees, 4,000 Islamic
State jihadis had already entered
Europe. On May 10th, 2016, Patrick
Cowbar, the head of France's DGSI,
Internal Intelligence Agency, said that
the Islamic State was using migrant
routes through the Balkans to get
jihadis into Europe. But none of this
information has been allowed to
interfere with Barack Obama's fantasies.
Meanwhile, back in the real world, the
Islamic State celebrated Eidala by not
only slaughtering animals, but by
hanging men it had designated as US
spies upside down from meat hooks and
slaughtering them like sheep. It might
have been illuminating for Obama to have
taken a moment to explain how and why
that was not a proper celebration of
this feast of fellowship and love and
why Muslims must reject the
understanding of Islam offered by the
Islamic State. But while he has
repeatedly asserted that the Islamic
State is not Islamic, he has never
bothered to explain exactly why and how
it isn't or how this misunderstanding of
Islam became so widespread. That's how
things work in fantasies. We don't know
how Mary Poppins can fly. We don't know
how Harry Potter can make things
disappear with a wave of the wand. They
just can. For Obama, Islam is a religion
of peace. It just is. And no
proliferation of infidels hanging from
meat hooks will disturb his comforting
fantasy. I'm Robert Spencer.